what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so I have been reading the x-men
for over 20 years you know I've been
reading the X minutes long as Sal over a
common pop has been reading spider-man
and to me the x-men I think I've always
been more interesting than the Avengers
and to me it's all it's so disappointing
to see the x-men just sort of wasted you
know in the in the Fox universe and so
if the x-men end up going into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe then my
question is how would they look what
would it be like him so because you guys
really seemed to enjoy the video that we
did unlike the Fantastic Four and the
x-men joining the MCU I figured that we
would take our movie days where we talk
about like you know movies and cover
book form you know for Marvel and MDC
and we're going to make a video on how I
think the phases of x-men in the MCU
would progress or at least how I would
love to see it done much like we saw in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe up-to-date
it's gonna be in phases it's gonna be
phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 to me the cool
thing about what's happened in the MCU
so far is that what we have gotten
pretty much nothing but 20 some-odd
movies featuring the same characters
what the x-men being introduced into the
MCU would do is it would give people a
chance to have a reprieve of sorts it
would give people a break from Captain
America and Thor and Iron Man showing up
in everything all the time instead in
this in this video and in my view for
the x-men MCU they would just be
referenced or you might see them in
flashbacks or something along those
lines but the first thing you do the
first origin that you go with in the
x-men MCU is the origin of Professor X
and the reason why is because while he
may not necessarily be the most popular
of the x-men he's certainly the most
important because he's the one who
started it all and that's what you cover
in this in this in this movie you
initially start off with the early days
of Professor X Professor X had a mom and
he had a dad and his dad died in lab
experiment and his dad's best friend
Kurt Marko married his mom and he
brought Ken Marcou who became Charles
Xavier stepbrother and the two of them
hated each other but of course Ken
Marcou learns the professor acts as a
telepath that he's a mutant he hates him
even more because Cain Marko thinks that
Xavier is better than him or something
along those lines but that wars the
story progresses you basically find out
that Kurt Markos in it for the money
eventually Charles Xavier mom dies Kurt
Marko dies in a fire that's set by a son
and that's the end of that fast-forward
to the Korean War and the Korean War
Professor X and Cain Marko were fighting
alongside each other they eventually
stumble across a temple Cain Marko
basically sees this inscription that
says whosoever touches this gem shall
possess the power of
crimson bands of cyttorak hints you who
read these words shall go forward
forevermore
a human juggernaut Ken Marcou becomes
the juggernaut you don't really see them
fight because Xavier would get the crap
beat out of him if they did you know hey
Marco realizes he has power on par with
his brother I'm gonna get you Professor
X you know and then he leaves and that's
the end of him we don't see him for
quite some time following this you
follow Xavier he meets magneto for the
first time and you lightly touch on the
origin of Magneto just slightly just
barely but from there you basically move
forward a bit where Xavier shows up in
Egypt one day now when he's in Egypt
he's picked pocketed by a young girl you
do not tell the audience who that girl
is the Internet will take care of the
rest in Marvel Comics that girl was
storm when she was a little girl when
she was a little kid you don't tell
anybody that you let the Internet take
care of it or you let people speculate
and that's it one of the big revelations
in this movie is basically the character
of the Shadow King the main villain from
the legion FX series and what you
basically do is you say somewhere along
the line when Xavier was in Egypt you
came across a super powerful telepath
the two of them engaged in a psychic
battle Xavier realized that if he lost
it would mean certain doom he won by the
skin of his teeth
but Xavier came to the realization that
if there are villains out there like
that who are that powerful and have no
remorse and are just basically evil
there has to be a team to combat those
threats and so that's when Xavier has
the ideology to form the x-men the
problem with this is he also listens he
also thinks about the origin story of
Magneto and what he basically says is if
there is going to be a team like the
x-men people are gonna think that we're
basically training to take over humanity
humanity is gonna be scared of us and so
we need to find a way to keep ourselves
hidden from them and so what he does is
he literally uses his powers Xavier
basically wipes the wipes all knowledge
of mutants from across the face of the
earth on everybody who exists on earth
itself that's why the x-men have never
been seen or referenced in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe what you do is you
literally tie it to Infinity Ward
somewhere along the line when vision got
the mind stone because the mind stone
allows him to basically read the minds
of every being in existence and allows
him to overpower the psychic blocks of
Charles Xavier vision learned about
mutants and instead of just spilling the
beans to everybody he takes the most
logical approach and goes to visit
Charles Xavier and Charles Xavier tells
him why this has been done and then
that's it that's how the x-men are in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Xavier hid them from
everybody in existence and vision found
out about it but didn't tell anyone
because Xavier asked him not to
from there you go into the second movie
the origin of magneto this would
basically take a lot of stuff from
magneto from x-men apocalypse which
already existed in Marvel Comics albeit
you know x-men apocalypse changed it a
bit what we would do is we would go with
the original x-men or in your origin
story for magneto I think it was classic
x-men number 112 or something along
those lines the whole idea is that you
basically grab magneto Testament and the
origin of magneto and you throw them
into one story magneto Testament was a
story that was written by Greg Pak that
was designed to basically tell us what
happened during the early days of world
war two when Magneto's family was thrown
in a concentration camps and essentially
what had happened is that some members
of his family believed the Germans would
never come for them others did and said
we have to get out while we can Germans
came knocking on their door they were
all swept off to camps while he was in a
concentration camp magneto became
extremely capable in the various skills
that he had he didn't initially know
that he had the power of magnetism
instead he was just very capable he was
duplicitous he would manipulate he would
do whatever is it he had to do in order
to ensure that the time that he was in
those camps alongside the people he
cared about passed as easily as possible
he would bribe guards he would give them
food he would give them gold different
things like that the result is that he
effectively sort of rose in the ranks
and became part of a group of freedom
fighters that were working to liberate
the camps now this is where you roll in
the greater Marvel Cinematic Universe or
at least Captain America and Bucky
Barnes and Marvel Comics during World
War Two Steve Rogers Captain America and
Bucky Barnes were basically one part of
a superhero team called the invaders the
other part was named on the Submariner
and the original Human Torch Jim Hammond
they basically fought against the Axis
powers liberating camps so on and so
forth
you hold that in to the Magneto movie
but following the liberation of this
camp you follow the origin story of
magneto the way it always happened in
Marvel Comics you know he's basically
freed from the camps he along side Magda
go out in the world try to start a life
for themselves they get false identities
they end up going into some you know
some town in the rural mountains of
Europe people eventually find out that
magneto is lying about his identity they
find out that he actually has powers
that he's a mutant they're terrified of
him they try to run him out in doing so
they burn his house down and his
daughter dies in the process the result
is that magneto freaks out he loses his
mind kills everybody in the village
his wife freaks
she runs off but she's pregnant with
twins and magneto doesn't know it the
result is that you know his wife Magda
basically takes off eventually runs into
the High Evolutionary assuming Marvel's
able to use that character eventually
gives birth to twins probably dies in
the birthing process and then the
internet will basically reveal the fact
that Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch
that's who they become but from there
you go into the first x-men movie and
the first x-men movie is the most basic
movie it's the simplest movie it's
basically the formation of the original
x-men team as is brought together by
Charles Xavier and they fight magneto
and that's it magneto returns waging
this vendetta against humanity he's
taking all of his experiences from world
war ii and the village of people that
you know killed his daughter and so on
and so forth you grab all that stuff you
throw it in and you basically say
magneto does not want to see that happen
to mutants and so the result is that
he's waging a war against humanity he
travels to Cape Citadel in Florida or
whatever it is he tries to launch
nuclear weapons the x-men show up at the
behest of Xavier they stop Magneto
movies done roll credits from there you
go into the origin film of Jean Grey
x-men origins Jean Brent and what it
does is it grabs two separate stories
from Marvel Comics and it merges them
into one the first story is the x-men
origins Jean Grey comic the second and
probably the most important story in
terms of laying the groundwork for what
comes later is bizarre adventures number
27 now the original x-men origins Jean
Grey story literally just detailed the
idea of Jean Grey being a little kid not
necessarily being able to control her
powers eventually getting the attention
of Charles Xavier because of the fact
that her powers want to rise somewhere
along the line when she was in a mall or
something like that
any tought Jean how to use her abilities
what you do is you take that story and
you modify it with bizarre adventures
number 27 back when Chris Claremont took
over the x-men in 1975 bizarre
adventures was an ongoing series of
publications that I think largely
featured kazar but bizarre adventures
number 27 told the origin of Jean Grey
as it existed at the time and what it
did is it said that instead of Jean
Grey's parents contacting Xavier what
had happened was Jean Grey's friend who
was a you know a little girl at the time
was killed more or less and the result
is that Jean Grey basically used her
telepathy to bond with this girl's mind
in her final moments and all Jean Grey
felt was fear and anger sadness the
whole nine yards because the emotional
output was so overwhelming Jean sort of
let out this psychic backlash that had
two main purposes the first
that it alerted Charles Xavier to her
existence the second is it alerted the
Phoenix force to her existence and
that's why I would grab his our
adventures number 27 you don't do
anything stupid like you know she has a
psychic backlash and then the Phoenix
forces in her eyes you have something to
indicate that Jean will become the
Phoenix later on down the line that's a
little world-building part but the
result is that because of our actions
Xavier shows up you know whether he
reaches out to her telepathically
whatever the case may be and says I can
help you get through this and I can help
you learn to use your powers from that
point you jump into x-men 2 and x-men 2
basically picks up after the first x-men
film and what you do is you basically
create this new generation of x-men and
you roll them over with the first
generation of x-men you do exactly what
Marvel did in giant-size x-men number
one those are guys who don't know
because of the fact that Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby and Roy Thomas is handling of
the original x-men line was so unpopular
what ended up happening is Marvel tried
to find a way to basically bridge the
cap between a new x-men team and the old
x-men team and so in giant-size x-men
number one what they did is they
basically established that somewhere
along the line the original team was
captured by a living Island called Kirk
Owen and what it did is it took the
x-men captain Cyclops manages to make an
escape quote-unquote he shows back up to
Charles Xavier Xavier says fine we need
to form a new team to rescue the first
team that's when you get the x-men that
you're familiar with that's when you get
storm that's when you get Colossus
Nightcrawler Wolverine Banshee if you're
if you've been reading along enough to
know who that guy is
that's when you start getting all those
characters this massive expanse of the
x-men roster but the whole idea is that
this new generation of x-men races off
to the living island of krakoa
they rescue the old x-men both groups
return they merge together into a
singular team roll credits done from
there you go into the gambit film and
the gambit film is basically x-men
origins gambit that's all it is you grab
that cut up of one shot and you throw it
into film form while adding a few things
in there and kind of modifying a little
bit of history with the x-men origins
gambit story it established one major
thing for his character and that was the
idea that gambits powers were beyond his
ability to control and so what he did is
you sought out a mutant geneticist by
the name of Nathaniel Essex you do not
tell the audience who Nathaniel Essex is
you let the internet take care of that
now Nathaniel Essex tells gambit I will
help you with this but I'm gonna call in
a favor later on down the line gambit
says okay I'll go
the internet will take care of the rest
but the whole idea is that gambits
powers are basically reduced by an
artificial lobotomy more or less in the
sense that Nathaniel Essex removes a
portion of gambits brain and his powers
are controllable now from that point
gambit goes off he does his own thing
and he eventually meets storm storm is
basically on a mission of sorts from
Charles Xavier more of a humanitarian
effort to find various mutants who want
to join the x-men cause if they do
they're brought to the team if they
don't storm wishes them good luck and
she goes about her business but in this
movie you bring in things like the
Thieves Guild the Assassin's Guild
that's how all that stuff happens you
bring all that into the film you're
doing in a way to make sense but you
really just kind of bring it all
together so that you flesh out gambits
backstory to a degree the reason why
that matters is because of the next film
mutant massacre when gambit rolls over
into the x-men none of the x-men know
about his history we as the audience
know about his history with the
exception of the favorite Earth annual
Essex called in but we know everything
else the x-men don't know anything about
it and so the result is that the mutant
Massacre story is told one half as
flashback the other half as what's going
on in the modern day the x-men basically
learned that somewhere along the line
Nathaniel Essex the favor he called him
was that he believed in the sewers of
New York were various Morlocks that he
had created and so what he did is he
formed a team called the Marauders that
were led by gambit and the result is
that gambit once he got into the tunnels
of New York realized it was going to be
a massacre and backed out but the x-men
basically believed gambit had a hand in
the mutant Massacre now the Morlocks are
basically just a group of mutants that
live below the sewers of New York who
have either you know who have powers
that basically changed their physical
form that makes them kind of castoffs in
society or their powers are
uncontrollable and so the result is that
they live in the sewers of New York kind
of isolated from everything else but the
character Nathaniel Essex is a villain
named mr. sinister and he believed that
he had created the Morlocks and so in
order to eliminate his creation from the
world he contracted the Marauders to
take out the Morlocks but in the
original mutant massacres story the
x-men believed that gambit was the one
responsible for the elimination of all
these Morlocks they kicked him off the
x-men team and that's exactly what
happens here this sets the stage for the
second gambit film which won't come for
a little while but after the mutant
master curse story you go into the final
film of the first phase which I consider
to be probably the most popular film
would be the origin of Wolverine now the
reason why I say this movie for the very
is because this is where you get the
most world-building when it comes to the
x-men in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and their place in relation alongside
all the other superheroes who were there
Wolverines existed for a few hundred
years and you do that you basically say
hey at this point along the line
Wolverine popped his claws for the very
first time learning had a healing factor
you can tie as origin in with everything
else that goes on and then you just go
through and have them just kind of fight
in various wars various conflicts
different things like that you hop skip
and you jump over some of the most
important moments in his life until you
get to the 1960s and the reason why you
get into the 1960s is because this
details a huge expansion with regards to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe when it
comes to the MCU you can kind of view it
as something on the front side all you
see is what the superheroes have done
there's not much going on in terms of
world building it's just here's the
superheroes and here's their villains
and here's what they fight together done
what would you do with Wolverine is you
provide this hold back in that nobody
ever knew about before and what you
would basically say is that in the 1960s
after fighting in world war ii fighting
alongside Captain America Wolverine was
swept up in the CIA and when he was in
the CIA he worked for a black ops team
called team X and all team X did is it
went through and carried black ops
missions out it eliminated dictators it
toppled you know corporations it did
whatever it is the CIA wanted Team X to
do but what you also do is you bring in
two concepts the first is weapon plus
and the second is project right away now
with weapon Plus and Marvel Comics its
starkly different from what we're gonna
do in this film and Marvel Comics weapon
plus had this great big huge weird you
know origin that we don't need to go
into you're welcome to look it up I've
got a video on the whole history of
weapons Plus and weapon X you're welcome
to check that out that would tack on
another 20 minutes to this video which
we're not gonna do weapon plus was a
government-sponsored project that served
the purpose of analyzing the mutant
threat and trying to find a way to
contain or eliminate the mutant threat
now webbing Plus was basically an
umbrella name under weapon plus you had
weapons one two three four all the way
up to weapon tenth weapon one was
Captain America the problem with this
was that in Marvel Comics Abraham
Erskine died before he could give
anybody the Super Soldier Serum and so
there could be no more Captain America's
that was it in response to this weapon
Plus began developing all the other
projects weapons one two three four all
the way up to weapon ten it was
things like turning people into cyborgs
which is where you got nuke the guy that
you saw in the Jessica Jones TV series
who was popping the red and the blue
pills that's new by the time it got to
weapon ten what had happened is weapons
Plus had basically become a joint
venture between the CIA and Canada
special ops division of call department
cake and what ended up happening is you
ended up having the CIA alongside
Department K analyzed Team X and they
came to the realization that Wolverine
James haloth basically had a healing
factor not only that these other members
of Team X had healing factors and so
what they ended up doing is they ended
up grabbing those characters they threw
them into the weapons the temp iteration
of weapons Plus which was weapon ten
weapon X and then gave them adamantium
and a new course Wolverine escape you
grabbed that concept and you roll it in
but you add to it the idea of project
wide awake now project wide awake in
Marvel Comics was created by Chris
Claremont I'm pretty sure and it was the
whole idea of like the the mutant
Registration Act two different things
like that but it was a multi-faceted
joint venture between like the President
of the United States and like the
National Security Council and the
National Security Agency and the FBI and
the CIA and the whole purpose of project
wide awake was to analyze the mutant
threat and then control the mutant
threat now the whole idea is you grab
that project wide awake and you throw it
into the Wolverine origin story what you
basically do is you establish that as
the origin for weapon plus you say the
federal government came to the
realization in the 1960s there was this
huge explosion of the mutant population
and for whatever reason whether it was a
fear of being replaced by mutants
whether it was a fear because mutants
would eliminate humanity when they waged
war against them humanity began the
process of creating all these different
projects for the purpose of trying to
find a way to control contain or
eliminate the mutant threat and Matt
brazen weapon plus Steve Rogers Captain
America was the first thing that's when
you provide that whole back into it
behind the scenes Captain America was
created for the purpose of eliminating
mutants he just didn't know it because
Abraham earth scheme died before it
happened and his training was
quote/unquote never completed but after
Captain America went forward during
World War two and then he was frozen in
a block of ice for 20 years and
eventually thought out what happened was
behind the scenes all these different
things with weapon plus were going on
and you grabbed Nick Fury
you roll him in and say he knew about it
the entire time he just didn't tell
anybody what was going on Natasha
Romanoff as part of the Red Room is one
facet of another country's version of
and plus you grab all those things and
you throw them all in to one great big
huge melting pot and he provide this
massive back-end to the whole idea of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe that it's
not necessarily as you know nice and
lovey as we would like it to be though
there's some really dark undertones to
it and so the result is that you have
Wolverine eventually escaped from the
facility after having adamantium grafted
to his bones and the movie ends that's
it that's done but it's a massive amount
of world building a lot of it would just
be like huge you know expositions on
weapon Plus where it came from how its
highs in the Captain America you could
even argue that Howard Stark knew about
weapons Plus and he's the one that
helped to design some of the cybernetic
implants the whole idea is you would
basically build up this huge facet of
the MCU he would do so much world
building that it would really grab the
x-men and say yep they're just as much a
part of the MCU as everybody else and
here's how so that's how you would in
the first phase that's phase one of the
MCU massive world building massive
exploration introducing the x-men
establishing the idea that the x1 aren't
just a team of mutants that do some
stuff there's a lot of history there but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here - comments explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the robb cork do you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
leave a comment down below let me know
if you guys want to see like Phase two
or something along those lines because
I'm kind of curious to see what you guys
think but anyway guys we're gonna bring
this to an end and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]